un petit peu pour voir d'où vient l'eau
Michel Gratton vit tout près de
l'immense marin à hammurst à quelques
pas de sa maison
l'été c'est magnifique dit-il les arbres
bougent comme les vagues sur la mer
c'est beau devoirs mais les jours de
tempête il est inquiet parce que
vraiment ça juste unisme puis il y a de
l'eau des deux bords
voici du haut des airs c'était tendu de
marais des kilomètres de territoires
plats bordés de beaucoup d'eau d'un côté
il y a la baie de Fundy et de l'autre le
détroit dans le Timberland au centre ce
sont les marais de l'isthme de chicnic
to la bande de terre qui relie la
Nouvelle-Écosse au reste du pays une
bonne partie de l'ishme est sous le
niveau de la mer il y a donc des digues
comme ici pour le protéger de la baie de
Fundy qui est un peu plus loin surtout
que dans la baie il y a les plus hautes
marées au monde la question que de plus
en plus de gens se posent est-ce que
c'est infrastructure de terre sera
prévenir encore longtemps l'inondation
de l'ishme et par conséquent des
quartiers comme celui de Monsieur gratte
je sais pas que j'ai tellement peur mais
je suis nerveux de temps en temps
seulement de temps en temps le restant
du genre c'est parfait ici
de temps en temps c'est quand des
tempêtes se dirigent vers la région
comme l'inoubliable tempête post
tropicale Fiona lorsqu'elle a violemment
touché terre en Atlantique en septembre
dernier l'eau et le vent ont fait
énormément de dégâts ils ont même
détruit des maisons des placées des
chalets
le maire de hammerzt nous montre tout ce
qui pourrait inonder il trouve la
situation angoissante
les tempêtes deviennent plus intenses et
elles sont plus fréquentes en Atlantique
d'idées elles font de plus en plus peur
ici Fiona avait foncé droit sur l'ishme
de Shining to est-ce que les digues
auraient tenu le coup se demande-t-il
ce serait impensable un désastre dit-il
un tiers de sa ville pourrait se
retrouver sous l'eau selon lui et sa
province coupée du reste du Canada parce
que le chemin de fer et la France
canadienne traversent l'isthme de chez
Nick to d'ailleurs de l'eau côtoie déjà
une partie du chemin de fer
est devenu un important corridor
commercial entre la Nouvelle-Écosse et
le reste du pays il y a un va-et-vient
constant de camion et train qui
transporte de grandes quantités de
marchandises ces échanges commerciaux
valent plus de 50 millions de dollars
par jour
notamment parce que des navires de
partout dans le monde à cause au port
d'alifax puis on voit leur cargaison
dans le reste du Canada et aux
États-Unis en passant par ici
de l'autre côté de l'ishme c'est le
Nouveau-Brunswick là aussi on crée ce
scénario catastrophe surtout dans la
ville de tentramar à l'entrée de la
province c'est assez proche des marais
puis on est toujours conscient que en
arrière 700 les marais démarrer tout
aussi inquiétant qu'en Nouvelle-Écosse
pour Sabine elle est la directrice
générale de climat atlantique un
organisme sans but lucratif qui cherche
des façons de s'adapter au changement
climatique faut vraiment être conscient
que le risque est réel c'est pas quelque
chose qui oh ça fait arriver en 2100 non
excusez-moi c'est pas ça c'est vraiment
regarde si on a qu'est-ce qui est arrivé
à actionna je pensais il y en a vraiment
une manque de compréhension comment
urgent que c'est les gouvernements de la
Nouvelle-Écosse du Nouveau-Brunswick et
du Canada sont d'accord qu'il faut agir
il se donne 10 ans pour élever les
digues et faire d'autres travaux de
protection c'est du moins ce qu'a
recommander un rapport l'année dernière
non
mais c'est trop tard affirme le maire de
tan-tramar il le répète à qui veut bien
l'écouter
un problème national et non pas
seulement de la région et que le temps
presse puisqu'il en va du bien-être des
communautés et de l'économie mais
peut-être qu'il n'en sera rien peut-être
que Michel Gratton pourra continuer de
vivre paisiblement près des marées à
meurst
l'année passée puis on a acheté un extra
pompe il essaye tout de même de protéger
sa maison parce qu'il voit comme une
ombre au tableau comme une inquiétude
qui ne part pas
ici Michel Brideau Radio-Canada Hamers
en Nouvelle-Écosse